But like Tom Cruise was like,
is like so famous. And then he did the crazy,
like I'm in love, I'm in love, you know,
with Katie Holmes and then got like,
people started talking about how he was in Scientology Institute and then got a
little bit, people were like, Whoa, what's going on? And then for sure,
his PR told him to shut that down because he stopped doing that.
And then he just kind of was like, okay, well let me just do book,
ghost protocol and take on my craziness in how I am just going to run across
buildings with a wire tethered to the top. Like, like I'm a tetherball dude.
Tom cruise was a straight up tetherball in that movie, man, ghost protocol,
you know the name of it. Ha
ghost protocol.
I feel like that mission impossible movie was the big you as like, okay,
you're going to let us get away with calling them whatever we want. Let's see.
Ghost protocol. What was the thing?
Tweet that Delaney did Rob Delaney about
ghost protocol. It made me laugh so hard.
It was when it came out and he was like alternate names that they were going to
use. Rob Delaney. And it was ghost protocol.
What were the names? Is it down there? It would probably be the top one now.
Right. Protocol to writing protocol up there.
And that's a hundred percent obvious one fire.
Uh, well.
Let's just read all of his tweets that say about cost protocol.
I bet he's so he did Rob Delaney. So funny. Uh,
I mean, do it,
I think he was on a tear with the movie on, I only actually fist fight my dad.
The only actual, the only I love when he,
the only where did it go, the only app full fist fight.
My dad and I ever got into was when I said Tom Cruise's hair looked coolest,
Helen [inaudible] protocol. And he laughed go down a little more.
Oh, here we go. Title's considered for mission impossible.
Oh, here we go. Click on that. He wrote op.
Probably get him, bro. I'll probably get in trouble for posting this,
but I found a document at paramount pictures that lists the titles they
considered for the new mission.
Impossible film before settling on the excellent ghost protocol,
please repost in case they take it down from my site. Mission,
impossible loaf, mission, impossible,
plop, centrifuge, centrifuge,
mission, impossible con Sullivan.
Wow. This is what the internet was made for mission impossible.
Beef pamphlets
Missing impossible frost, debutantes,
like kids said the next one it's got the N-word and
Mitch calibrate Fern gabled tooth peach bottle,
top North wiggle down
blankets. Squirt w wow. He's funny, dude.
That guy's funny as, huh? It's annoying.
Our funny idiot. He is passive.
Accident. Moreover.
Ward on my mind,
call it Tom cruise on Tom cruise Scientologist.
I think it's a privilege to call yourself a Scientologist.
And it's something that you have to earn.
And because Scientologists does he.
A Scientologist, does.
She has the ability to create new and better realities and
improve conditions, uh, being Scientologists. You look at someone and you know,
absolutely that you can help them.
Well, you know, just killing it at life.
I want to be like that. I want to just walk, that, dude.
I'm going to be Scientologist. I want to just walk into a room and just,
no, do you understand what I'm saying? A blanket
knowledge of what the is going on.
And I swear to God too.
I'll not only they laid that song over the mission,
impossible song over this for some reason,
but I'll bring a straight up, not iPhone iPod,
a separate iPod with speakers that connect and don't
Bluetooth in and I will straight up play
it case.
While I walked in the room. It's, it's something that
I don't mince words with, that we know bro,
with anything I'm a Scientologist policy to me has really gone well,
how do I do it? Every I know I just kind of went through and said,
you know what? When I read it, I just went.
Yes. It said is exactly it.
Go said nothing. And that's what I want to do.
When people ask me about Scientology and I'm focused straight right now,
whatever the first step is, I did it probably realizing that you want to be it.
You know, that's probably what it is. If you look at the Scientology book,
they're like, yo, first step is straight up realizing you want it.
You need help. There we go. I'm on my babies.
And I go and I go like this and I go and I go and people ask me about
Scientology and, whenever I finished the program,
whenever they get all their dirt on me or whatever they go, like,
they go like now you're cytologists because you gave us some dirt and I go like
this. Cool. And then people say, what's up with psychologist.
And I go like this dude, when I looked at Scientology straight up,
the thing was, was like a light bulb went off. Like I looked at it and I,
and I read what it was about. And our first, when I first saw it,
I was just like, forget it. I was like, forget it.
And then somebody asked me about it.
And that was the first time they talked about and I was like, what's going on?
And they looked at me and I was like, you know what? I know, I know what's up.
I walk into a room and you just, you feel it right.
He or she can walk into a room and just feel it. And I get an a very,
and that's the thing. What's the thing. The thing is, is just,
you know, it's a being, it's a presence.
It's an essence where you walk in and you just,
you have that because you've done the steps and you've worked and now you're
mashed potatoes and people are just like, wait, what? And you're just like, no,
now your mashed potatoes. I was like, well, he didn't really say much.
He definitely said he was mashed potatoes. That's the thing about Scientology.
You know, you know, you walk in and like a light bulb went off.
When you first read those words, you read that. And you know,
a light bulb went off and you're finding, you know, that you can help and,
and all of a sudden your mashed potatoes and it's all good. And they're like,
wait, what?
I'm gonna get dirt on you. And your mashed potatoes.
Cruz straight up, looked at an interviewer and said, I'm mashed potatoes.
They would believe it. That's the thing I want to get to.